[Music]
his girlfriend
it's a situation I don't think that that
title was necessary unless you think
about the next step
[Music]
hi hey man how are you can I get a hug
how are you
come on it was nice too and nice too
see you again good to see you
how you doing it's kind of weird going
on a date with a friend it's uh like
I've never even seen you as like
anything more than a friend
mm-hmm
is that right yes okay well let's
conduct it as such okay all right
what do you want to know oh we acting
like we don't know each other no
no I just said that like I've never like
it's kind of different going on a date
with somebody you already know or know a
lot about okay what's something I don't
know about you I don't know what you
don't know about it you probably looking
on my goddamn YouTube page searching
everything oh really really okay yeah
you're right you're right I'm obsessed
I'm obsessed yeah no but I like I like
the fit though you do yeah does that say
Tom Ford yes you know who picked out
these pants for me wait a minute you
came here with the best threads that you
could find that means that must mean a
lot no these are like every day every
day yeah it is every day everyday type
of pants look Tom Ford and I used to
work at Vogue did you know that no I
didn't know the two books that are back
there I worked at vote I hacked my way
into getting into vote but I have a
question because the ladies want to know
you said you've been single since
College yeah you're 37 now yeah there's
not one girl that you found out there
that you felt like was enough for you to
at least make her your girlfriend
um here's the thing when I say single
what I mean by that is defined as
I say that she's my girlfriend
and she says that I'm her boyfriend
I've been in situations situation ships
since College okay but when it comes to
that title I don't think that that title
was is necessary unless you think about
the next step
so many women need to take in if a man's
not going to see you in public and say
you're his girlfriend
it's a situationship and you need to
take it at face value when you say it
don't think oh yeah
I think he might have had girlfriends
like that lasted yes moms but you never
actually said yeah you're my girlfriend
I think that's the problem with my um
with women they think they can
they think they can change a man when
he's already shown who he is but what's
wrong with that dude
no because I feel like a lot there's not
necessarily nothing wrong with it but
there's a lot of women that have this
savior complex and think they can change
a man but a man won't change unless he
wants to change himself what's wrong
with it is that is that they both have
completely different expectations of
what's happening and so she's in this
delusion that she's in a relationship
with somebody and if he won't claim her
publicly then you're just a it
could be a for two years right who
wants to just be a for two years
unless it's unless
I mean like delusion like if if that's
your reasons yeah
that's kind of hard if that's her
intention that's the reason it is
honestly it's more on women why do we
put ourselves in those situations why
don't we take your actions because it's
fact like your actions speak louder than
your word so you can be saying oh I love
you and all this blah blah blah but if
you won't introduce me to your friends
and take me out and show me off and be
proud of me that means you don't it's
just all words to get you I love you and
his IG and this is why it's important to
wait to not just you know have sex with
them straight away because if you wait
you filter out the men who only see you
as like something to sleep with
and then the real ones who actually see
you as something special can get to know
you and then see you as more than just
sex so it's quite he's an honest person
there's someone out there that say yeah
you're my girlfriend and they'll
you for a couple of years and still W
yeah but at least he's being honest so
now you know that if a man doesn't say
I'm your you're my girlfriend but
there's men out there that will say
you're my girlfriend you might be a
girlfriend you're not a wife you're not
a fiance you're just a girlfriend and
you've got to wait till marriage that's
the only solution to this I see so I'll
shut your legs with me like I got
friends in my life my homeboys that are
getting a like relationship here for a
couple of months and uh they single for
a little while outrageous there for a
couple months but I think like
um I take relationships seriously so if
I get into relationship it means that
I'm betting you for something more right
and when I say marriage I don't mean
like government sanctioned marriage I
don't know just to keep that funky but
um but yeah so I've had situations and
but at the end of the day what's
inevitable for me me was that I wasn't
ready at the time but I'm getting older
now male you know what I'm saying I'm a
business owner right you know what I'm
saying so I I be looking for a young
lady to form fit within a program do you
think that you have the skills and or
attributes and our characteristics to
form fit yourself within a program
oh absolutely really yeah talk about
that why do why do you think like what
would be the characteristics for that I
mean it's how I was raised my aspiration
in life was to be a housewife to be a
wife
um
um I I raised on a diet of that
um it's so for me it's it's I think
the conversation now a lot of women want
to be married but they don't necessarily
know what it means to be a wife they've
never seen it demonstrated they weren't
raised that way they don't get pleasure
a lot of women say for the right man
I'll be submissive and I think you know
submission is a heart attitude that you
just can't turn on and off but so many
women think well for the right man I can
be but submission is not meaning like
you're like you're groveling in under a
man it means an attitude of service an
attitude of you know how can I
um you know best
um meet the needs of a man and that can
be any man actually so
um submissive to my father submissive
too everyone's submissive a lot of women
don't realize you're submissive to your
boss you're submissive to your
supervisor you're submissive you're
submissive to a corporation you're
submissive
um a lot of times women are submissive
to boyfriends or men who are of low
value in terms of how they treat you but
and they'll go through all this stuff
but they'll say if a good man says I
need submission I won't this got really
serious no it did but it would be fun no
it can be but I think but I actually
know I think it raises a good question
so within this idea of submission let's
say that you know you know what I'm
saying like
we was trying to figure each other out
and I said like in order to be a part of
my program
I want you to relinquish what you
consider male friends within your life
as well as I want you to delete your
Instagram
as well
how would you feel about that I don't
have male friends now so I mean I mean
we're friends well through business okay
through business associate but I will
cut off any and every man
um Instagram okay so you want to cut me
off absolutely you got to go if you
don't like you you gotta go boo oh
all right so listen so I don't know how
many people know about your background
so you have all of these fantastic
um thoughts and or understandings of men
today so I guess so why are you single
right now
oh I was married for nearly 12 years 11
years and I got divorced how many times
you cheat
if you don't stop playing with me plan
on playing with my are you playing today
okay did not cheat did not file for
divorce but I I and I will not
disrespect the situation I was in but I
would just say
um more than cheating can lead to the
end of a marriage anybody who's been in
a long-term marriage will tell you that
um there's mental health there's death
there's a lot of things that can go on
but I took that that marriage uh you
know and the end of it and I you know
instead of turning to blame other people
blame men I I just did the introspective
work because
you know I knew a failure was a failure
whether I caused it I still contribute
it to the to the fall of it so you know
and and one of the things even though my
my that marriage was not good I loved
being a wife like I love cooking
cleaning decorating I love you know just
being domesticated I love this look I'm
on a man's face when you give him a
plate like I don't know it's just
it's just my thing so I don't know that
makes sense now here's the thing this is
odd in the sense that we know each other
I know right there's also odd in the
sense that I can't ask you questions
because I already know how you're gonna
like questions that would be typical to
understand more about you because I
already know how you're going to answer
the questions so in my mind I'm like how
do I ask questions that people so like
let me ask you this question because you
came in hot
you came in hot when you came in here
you came in hot you said something like
oh you friend I'm always consider you so
like
what would it take or why why do you
just consider me friend zone outside
let's say we didn't have a business
would you just consider me friend zone
if we was a business not what you're
looking for well there's two things one
you don't want a woman past the age of
40. you don't want a woman who already
has children
um so that already disqualifies us from
being yeah but you wouldn't know that if
we didn't know each other I mean just
talking to you I would find out or when
you ghost me after that
um no we live in two different places
and
you know like
I and and I am looking to get married
again very soon like if I no no no I
don't need government paperwork okay no
but I mean just have that marriage
relationship with a man
when are you looking to have that
marriage relationship no no right so
that is why we are friends
that move that I mean I use logic and
deductive reasoning like
I don't you know I want to be able to
whatever man be with like I can fit into
his program on those metrics alone I
don't fit into your program
do you find me attractive here's the
thing do you find me attractive you are
very attractive okay thank you young
lady thank you I just want to hear it
here's the thing how many people think
that you are 40 plus when they come in
and they meet you uh most don't when I
start speaking
a lot of people realize okay she's older
than what she says that you have right I
think that's another question
what is it like growing up uh with
pretty privilege
and how was that impacted or affected
the way that you think about
um
thoughts within this world
pretty privilege this is like these new
Concepts pretty privileged all these
other things it's not new so for me it
is a phrase for me it is but the the
impact is real because there's things
that you can say in or do that
ugly women cannot stand or do for
example when you did this date on your
side there's multiple times as you say
oh I got multiple personalities in my
head here that's ever was a two if it
was a two that was saying that like
that I'm like but would you be on a date
with a two like I have a big I'm an
introvert but you know I'm a jokester
I'm extroverted I can do different
voices you have allowances
you'll be on the date with the two
regardless of anything else
even if it wasn't date of course I
wouldn't be but let's just say like I'm
I'm meeting somebody right like let's
say it's a business situation yeah and
she says something that's off the wall
more often than not dues today will
allow the off-the-wall comments to come
from an attractive woman than an
unattractive woman like when you think
of like the hierarchy of like what this
is from like a gender perspective pretty
woman is at the top somewhere beneath is
like
men like all different calibers of men
right from a privileged perspective and
then out down at the bottom maybe like
you know but pretty privilege goes away
as you age like so you may not receive
it on the front end but the back end and
this is why women who are pretty feel
like they have Endless Options but as
you get older girl like that's going to
go away and there's there's a new pretty
girl every day that turns 18. so if you
if you're focused on your prettiness and
that's your value you're going to lose
the thing you value most about yourself
so I think about adding value with my
mind and who I am that's how I was
raised like I don't know and I'm
actually socially awkward that's you
know
it's so and a lot of people don't
believe it but I think I got away with
being socially awkward because I was a
girl who was cuter you know who was cute
I I didn't really think I was you know
some extraordinary beauty and I don't
think I am now but that's not where my
value lies like who cares
but speaking on my alternate
personalities many modern women wait
hold on many modern women today's values
is captured within how beautiful that
they are or their sexual being so I
understand what you're saying it's not
based off of your value but how it is
that you're perceived you know it can do
a lot in determining kind of the ease in
life yeah and if you're pretty as a
young woman you know you were born on
recruit difficulty but it's also a
poison it's a slow poison because you
look at Instagram just beautiful
Instagram models it's beautiful
actresses they're single they don't have
relationship they're aging out they're
they're truly Auntie Grandma status and
they've never been married or don't have
a man now so it is also a a a it's it's
a mirage and if you don't have the right
values it will actually lead you to a
life of loneliness where a woman who you
consider lesser looking than you knew
those like like can I be with
you I know your platform you talk to a
lot of men but there's so much what you
just said right there was so impactful
is how do you evade The Mirage yeah
because young women today we talk about
all day the unrealistic standards and
expectations we talk about all day about
the delusion so the thing is is how do
they avoid the Mirage
how do they avoid them being a five and
thinking that they are a 10.
how do we avoid that because I think
like at the end of the day one of the
things that I talk about so often is how
many average men are just ignored by
average women yeah
yeah they're they're would you ever talk
to women
by dating no no no we used to hit talk
so long way I mean like my content
perspective come again hello I'm gonna
let y'all deal with women
um yeah I I do have a desire to do that
that's in the works but do people want
to hear this on a date right now this is
not fun or spicy this is so
business-like you want to would you like
for me to take out my memo and my pen
and Pad can you find me attractive I do
I think you are attractive scaling one
to ten uh you can't use seven a three
yeah
that means 11. all right
no I do think you're attractive I I but
I think you have a lot of options out
there especially you know being
attractive
um you are on the taller side I think
you're well spoken you're educated
um I think you know you make great money
um but I you know what I think I think
it's gonna be an issue for you what's up
you've never actually been in a
long-term relationship and dealing with
a woman in the day-to-day and I think
you'll be very intolerant of things that
are like normal for growth and I don't I
think it'd be really hard to let a woman
live in your space
because you're used to just it being you
like and as we ate okay so do you ever
want that do you like or do you see
yourself do you think
how could you change that like my hope
is that a young woman that I would
settle on has a decent control of her
emotions
has a decent control on her levels of
irrationality understands that she is
more opt for irrational Behavior that's
my hope you know but at the end of the
day you're not gonna find a perfect
person well my hope is that she at least
understands her propensity to not lie in
logic and to be Reliant within her
feelings that's my hope at the end of
the day it's it's based off of my
decision so if I choose or selected a
rational young woman that is based off
of me I got to deal with the
consequences of that now what you may
think is irrational maybe normal female
things so like like how are your parents
still married no okay were they ever
married
yes they got divorced when I was about
seven when you're about seven do you
have any male role models or a guy you
can turn to who's been married a long
time I have a bunch of most of my
friends are married who you can talk but
married not a friend but an older guy
who can you can talk to say is this
normal is this something like how can am
I am I thinking this is the most when
this is light things this is just how
women are and it just needs time to grow
this might sound odd most of my friends
are older and married how old what'd you
say 40 plus
q37 that's old yeah well wow 40 plus
that's Uncle no but like 40 to 50. you
know what's so crazy though is that
here's the thing and I want to put
anyone on blast right now but there's so
many of them I'll be asking you know
how's the marriage going and the first
thing they say is
yeah
it's an exhale so I think I look at that
and I'm like well God damn
that's what I got to look forward is
there any benefit you think to men being
married nowadays no so I don't think
that there is and then when I say when
you say married I'm thinking
state-sponsored marriage I think that
there's incredible benefit of finding a
life partner okay without a doubt
especially as you get older in your 20s
and like that that like no like you
out there having a good time you know
you trying to build up on yourself but
when you start establishing foundation
and you start establishing who you're
going to be into the future right like
your Fridays and your Saturday nights
are not as important as your Saturday
and your Sunday mornings and the things
that you can do in order to continue to
create as opposed to go out to events to
consume
okay and you go 30 plus and that's what
you're going to be focused in on what
age range are you looking to date or
what's the age range you like in women I
grow you know ladies want to know yeah I
go younger like how young like what's
the age range give us a range
in their 20s like froze so from 21 to
29. for me it's a it's an equation you
gotta once you go beyond 30 plus it's
really a derivative of how bad that you
are to consider how bad you know what I
mean like bad like like how great that
you look oh Baddie okay when you say bad
I was like bad like in bad behavior I
was like what I forget
that's how we talk what up DC okay what
we're not going to do thumbs up okay
no
oh Lord what up this is a hot mess big
hot mess were there any red flags that
you saw today
Pearl
um were you watching behind scene hold
up hold up on the plane
what about this one
how did the final round go